on this episode of The Last of Us we
have everything from steamy French Kiss
action to chicken sandwiches
[Music]
sandwich it's fine
episode 2 entitled infected takes us
deeper into the contaminated Zone as
Joel Ellie and Tess tackle the game's
biggest obstacle doors blocked by debris
in this video we take a deep dive into
the episode its connection to the game
Easter eggs and more so make sure to
like And subscribe I may not cover every
show you watch but when I do it's great
we begin in Jakarta Indonesia two days
before the events that take place in
Austin Texas from episode one if you
remember the news on the radio when Joel
and Sarah are having breakfast they
reported a series of disruptions in
Jakarta affecting this city no doubt a
cause of the events were about to
witness a military officer by the name
of August Hideout has brought in
professor of mycology Ebu ratna mycology
is a branch of biology that focuses on
the study of fungi as she's brought
deeper into the Ministry of Health she's
asked to examine a specimen of fungi
which she identifies as osteocordyceps a
type of fungus what's interesting about
this is that one of its species called
ophiocordyceps unilateralis is known to
attach itself to ants work its way into
their brains and alter the ants Behavior
eventually killing it and releasing
spores from its head if you're
interested in learning more about head
exploding spores check out planet
Earth's jungle episode which inspired
creative director Neil druckman to
create the last of us what concerns the
professor however was how the sample was
prepared using cortisol corazol is a
histological stain used to visualize
certain structures and tissue samples
and commonly used to prepare samples
from humans to be examined under
microscopes but fungi can't survive in
humans how is it in this human sample
remember back in episode 1 Dr Newman
said that fungi can't survive in hosts
with temperatures higher than 94 degrees
but he theorized that if the World's
temperature were to rise fungi would
have to evolve presence of such a fungus
in a human sample suggests that this
Evolution has fine finally taken place
so the professor Ventures into the lab
to analyze this body for herself of note
is the bite mark on her leg which looks
similar to Ellie's bite we saw at the
end of episode 1. we briefly see the
professor cut it open and I'm no doctor
but whatever's in there does not look
normal no blood pours out and the fungus
has taken over we also see a bullet to
the head as the military officer later
States the woman was shot roughly 30
hours ago at a flower and grain Factory
West of the city when she attacked and
bit three of her co-workers whom were
put into quarantine and later executed
when they turned infected remember that
Indonesia at the time was ruled by a
military dictator so these kinds of
things aren't too far-fetched episode 1
hinted that the infection may have
spread with tainted flower Joel and
Sarah didn't have flour to make pancakes
for breakfast Sarah didn't eat Mrs
Adler's cookies because they were raisin
and Joel forgot to bring home a cake for
his birthday so they may have dodged a
bullet by not eating these cordyceps
infected goodies all made from hour the
game on the other hand is a bit more
vague when it comes to the origin of
this fungus providing us only with a
Texas Herald newspaper article that
hints that the fungus came through
tainted crops from South America and
Mexico remember in episode 1 that a bite
to the leg takes about 24 hours to
incubate so this woman got bit roughly a
day before heading to work so far this
is the first verifiable case of the
fungus in humans however we can't call
her patient zero because she too was bit
by a human a day prior to Turning it'll
be interesting to see if the show delves
deeper into its origins or if they'll
prefer to keep it a mystery inside the
victim's mouth are these fungal-like
tendrils similar to those found on Mrs
Adler they even move on their own after
being taken out in a room colored sickly
yellow no doubt a conscious Choice by
the creative team the professor hears of
the events which brought the infected
woman to the lab in fact 14 workers from
the factory are now missing you'll
notice the professor's hands Shake while
holding her tea knowing that this
evolved fungus has spread among the
human population and the chances of it
being contained are next to zero as a
professor of mycology she would have
likely been familiar with the work of Dr
Newman that's why when the military
officials asked for her help to create
medicine or a vaccine she says there are
none the only way to stop the spread is
to bomb the city with everyone in it she
has to be driven home to spend the last
remaining days of her life with her
family Flash Forward 20 years we find
Ellie in the fetal position bathed in
light the fetal position and image of
life you may have even noticed the
butterfly fluttering across the frame
symbolizing rebirth and metamorphosis
butterflies were hidden all throughout
episode 1. this light shining on her was
also how we first saw her last episode
she's become this visual representation
of the Firefly motto when you're lost in
the darkness look for the light Ellie is
that light and Humanity needs her the
last we saw of test Joel and Ellie they
were making their way through the rain
into the contaminated Zone Tess and Joel
found out Ellie Was Bitten three weeks
ago yet shows no signs of turning as
we'll find out later in the episode a
certain change from the game will really
nail home the fact that Ellie is immune
understandably Tess and Joel watch over
her with trepidation there's never been
anyone immune to the infection and Joel
just wants to take her back to the
quarantine Zone and find another way to
get their battery tests on the other
hand is a bit more Curious and wants to
know how exactly Ellie came to be in the
hands of the fireflies it infected no
less if you played The Last of Us DLC
Left Behind you'll know exactly what
happened Ellie was with her friend Riley
hanging out in the abandoned Mall when
she got bit now it's interesting to note
here that Ellie lies to Tess and says
she was at this mall by herself Riley is
never mentioned but we do know Riley
exists in the show Universe because of
this line from episode 1. was Riley a
terrorist
Riley is undoubtedly one of the reasons
Ellie would want to find a cure she too
was bit in the mall incident but
succumbed to the infection so Ellie
undoubtedly has some survivor's guilt if
she can be a part in finding a cure
maybe it'll ease this guilt Ellie and
Riley were also romantically linked so I
had a nice laugh when Tess asked Ellie
if she had any boyfriends that would be
on her Trail after her Marlene picked up
Ellie from The Abandoned mall and put
her in confinement knowing she was
infected she didn't kill her luckily
because of a promise she made to Ellie's
mom before Ellie was born a promise to
watch after her but with Marlene being
the head of the fireflies the safest
place for Ellie was the orphanage run by
fedra there Marlene could keep an eye on
her from afar Joel's hand is partly
broken likely a hairline fracture from
beating a federal Soldier to death like
most of the trauma in his life he
bottles it up and doesn't talk about it
Ellie will later ask him personal
questions including how he feels about
just killing a man but it goes nowhere
after a quick lunch break which includes
Ellie eating a delicate in this
post-apocalyptic World a chicken
sandwich Tess asks why Marlene and the
fireflies are so invested with her turns
out there's a firefly base camp with
doctors working on a cure Somewhere Out
West with Ellie being immune perhaps
she's the key to finding a cure of
course Joel thinks this is all [__]
he's heard the stories of camps out west
filled with doctors working on cures and
they're all Bs nonetheless he's willing
to continue on their Journey so they can
get that sweet sweet battery along the
way we come across the iconic Leaning
Towers of Boston also from the game and
I love the addition of these huge
craters where the military bombed cities
in an attempt to curb the spread as Tess
says it worked in Boston but not all
cities were as lucky there's also a fun
giraffe plushie these giraffes can be
found all throughout the game like in
Sarah's room abandoned houses and
foreshadow one of the game's most iconic
scenes along the way Ellie remarks that
it seems quiet she imagined a world with
rowing bands of Runners but she makes
reference to two types of affected we
haven't seen at least not yet the first
is a super infected that explodes fungal
spores on you these are likely bloaters
she also talks about infected with split
open heads that can't see in the dark
we'll see these monsters known as
clickers later in the episode they see
using sound like bats like bats if you
hear One clicking you gotta hide in the
game The Journey to the Capitol Building
takes us through a variety of locations
like skyscrapers workplaces and the
subway but for the purposes of brevity
the show has condensed it to two main
sets and damn do they look gorgeous
first is the abandoned Hotel the flooded
Hotel looks like it's inspired by the
hotel Grand a location that isn't seen
until Joel and Ellie visit Pittsburgh
notice how when Joel helps Ellie up he
glances at the wound on his fist he's
still worried that she could be infected
and you never want to have an open wound
around someone who could be sick with
tests having to go around debris to
unlock the way forward we get one of our
first one-on-one conversations between
Joel and Ellie Joel is under
understandably walled off there's no
point in him getting close with a girl
who they're going to leave anyway he
does however notice her switchblade it
was a gift from Ellie's mother remember
that Sarah spent a lot of time looking
at her father's switchblade in episode 1
and I put my money on this blade coming
into Ellie's possession later on in the
season Ellie asked Joel if he and Tess
are a thing in the game the two are
flirty with each other but it doesn't go
as far as the show where we see Tess
actually get in bed with him there is
however one really important Line near
the end of the episode that puts things
into perspective after it's revealed
Tess has been bit and she can no longer
continue the journey with them she tells
Joel I never ask you for anything not
even to feel the way I felt implying
that she was the one who had a thing for
him but he was emotionally unavailable
again this tracks this is a guy who has
lost everyone close to him his wife his
daughter and he risks losing his brother
who was last seen somewhere out in
Wyoming Joel knows you can't get hurt if
you don't get attached Joel also doesn't
answer Ellie's question about how he he
got to Boston the years between Sarah's
death and the events of the last of us
are filled with hellish memories Joel
contemplated suicide and did unspeakable
things to survive he tricked innocent
people into thinking he was hurt so that
he could steal their supplies or even
kill them it's no wonder he's not too
keen on telling Ellie about this time of
his life from the rooftop we can make
out hundreds of infected Tess tells us
that this fungus connects all of them
you step on cordyceps in one place it
could awaken a dozen infected in another
believe it or not the planet's largest
organism is not the blue whale but a
fungus in organ that spans nearly four
square miles so theoretically someone
stepping on it could send signals as far
as four miles away we'll see this play
out later in the episode when an
infected is shot and the tendrils
underneath it alert swarms of Runners
nearby I also found it interesting that
these infected writhe in the sunlight
likely because fungi prefer dark and
moist conditions we'll later see Joel
open up one of these tendrils and remark
that it's bone dry a signal that
whatever is nearby is likely dead their
Journey leads them to the Bostonian
Museum a set piece taken directly from
the game it's a bit ironic considering
this museum is all about Freedom when
they live in a world that's under
authoritarian control their luck runs
out when they uncover a fresh body
suggesting infected nearby the place is
filled with tons of dead infected and
the building itself looks and sounds
like it could collapse at any moment
which is something that happens to them
in both versions
I also love that the area they first
meet these clickers is part of the
Hands-On exhibit Joel warns Ellie that
clickers can't see rather use a form of
echolocation to navigate their
surroundings these clickers look
absolutely gorgeous but definitely not
something you'd want to encounter on
your own Joel shoots one and Tess lodges
and acts into the other a nice callback
to the games where you can do the same
the biggest change here from the game
however is Ellie getting bit it doesn't
happen in the game version but I
understand why they put it in here near
the end of the episode we find out Tess
was also bit in a matter of hours her
infection has spread like wildfire while
nothing has happened to Ellie this is to
hammer home the fact that she is indeed
immune something Joel and Tess had a
hard time wrapping their heads around
Tess keeps her injury hidden until the
final moments of the episode and Joel
helps manage her twisted ankle as they
make their way to the Capitol building
with tape no less one of the key
crafting ingredients from the game there
are some gorgeous shots taken directly
from the game here as well now let me
know if you caught Joel looking at as
well watch after Ellie descends the
latter this happens in the game too so
it's not just some random acting Choice
the watch is a symbol of his daughter
and the fact he now has Ellie under his
protection a girl almost the same age as
his daughter Joel is starting to see
what this Mission can be whether he
knows it consciously or not Joel's
adventure with Ellie is a chance at
Redemption a chance for him to ease the
guilty feels around his daughter's death
but with this comes a price if he grows
too attached to Ellie he could suffer a
fate worse than death the feeling of
losing a daughter again a person is
trying to avoid a fate worse than death
for Joel be losing a daughter again in
the first episodes behind the EP feature
red which I'll leave a link to in the
description below showrunner Craig Mason
even says that when Joel is protecting
Ellie at the end of the episode he
thinks it's his daughter in the final
moments of this episode Joel forgets
that the girl that is standing behind
him is not his daughter as they approach
the Capitol Building they notice there
are no fireflies around this is a bit of
a departure from the game where they
uncover a dead Squadron of them in the
subway tunnels inside is a gruesome
scene the fireflies they were supposed
to hand Ellie off to are all dead one of
them got sick and they all died in the
Skirmish in the game we find that the
fireflies are indeed dead here but it's
never known how these guys died whether
it was infected themselves or fedra
soldiers here is where we find some of
the biggest changes from the game in the
game at test tells Joel to take Ellie to
Tommy but in the show they don't really
know exactly where Tommy is and instead
she tells him to take her to Bill and
Frank's Bill and Frank are the B and
markings from Joel's Smuggler code those
people who would communicate with him
via songs on the radio Bill and Frank
might take an Ellie since Joel wants
nothing to do with her if Joel can bring
her to them maybe he can set right all
the terrible [__] he and Tess did in the
past their goodbyes are cut short when
one of the dead bodies comes to life and
Joel shoots it it lays atop this bed of
fungus which loops around the dead
body's hand which alerts the nearby
Runners to their presence with Tess a
few hours away from turning into one of
them remember a bite to the shoulder can
take anywhere from two to eight hours to
incubate she makes the ultimate
sacrifice by dumping gasoline and
grenades she can take out the infected
allowing Joel and Ellie to escape her
last words to Joel are save who you can
this scene plays out differently in the
game instead of infected descending on
the building it's fedra soldiers test
stays to defend while ajolinelli run and
she ends up taking two soldiers down
before being killed I personally like
the show version better to me it's
scarier and more fun and of course we
gotta talk about about that creepy kiss
earlier in the episode we saw the
professor extract these tendrils from
the infected woman in Jakarta and in
episode 1 we saw Mrs Adler use them to
latch onto her prey whether the show's
infected prefer to use the mouth as an
easy point of access remains to be seen
but whatever the case it gave me awful
memories of my first kiss in grade
school the Capitol Building explodes
leaving Joel and Ellie on their own to
continue their Journey with the last
shot of Ellie framed among the ruins
Joel has just lost one of the closest
people to him in his life and he simply
just walks away we are starting to see a
pattern with Joel and how he deals with
these relationships will Ellie be able
to bring down that wall now I hand it
over to you what did you think of the
latest episode of The Last of Us I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
be sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at Big story YT
until next time remember
hey